protests started in Hong Kong in late
September what had happened is the
Chinese government had come out and said
hey we know we promised your first fully
democratic election in 2017 but we're
going to approve any of the candidates
who can run people started protesting
and then a few days later the thing
really escalated it was when Hong Kong
police came out an unprecedented level
of force to crack down the protesters
which only further outraged a lot of
people in Hong Kong drove more people to
the streets where they're not shutting
down the financial district
so to understand what's really happening
here the larger forces at work you have
to go back to 1997 that's the year of
what people in Hong Kong called a
handover when it went from under the
last vestiges of the British Empire to
part of China as part of the handover
China promised that Hong Kong would be
able to keep this really unusual level
of freedom and it would get to have
these first fully democratic elections
in 2017 it's called the one country two
systems policy so when China reneged a
little bit on its plan for the 2017
elections it looked to a lot of people
in Hong Kong like it was the beginning
of an end or one country two systems and
the thing that you have to understand is
that it's about more than just democracy
all that that's important there's a kind
of sense of Hong Kong exception some
people there are much more affluent much
more worldly they really see themselves
as very distinct from the rest of China
and any move like this that feels like
it's pulling them in to the dictatorial
rule of the Communist Party in China is
very scary to them and part of what
really makes that so scary is the memory
of Tiananmen Square right which happened
in 1989 in Beijing that memory is much
much stronger in Hong Kong where they
hold an annual vigil every year they're
keeping the flame alive for the fellow
Chinese who can't so that when police
started coming out in force
late in these protests they thought hey
this doesn't look like Hong Kong this
looks like Beijing so what you're seeing
is not just a fight for can we keep the
election rules that we have for two
17 it's a fight for can they stay Hong
Kong or they going to become just like
the rest of China